let's continue with our team coverage  with victoria saha she's live  near the strip with more reaction to  this guilty verdict victoria  a lot of folks here on vacation they  didn't even know that the verdict was  read  we did get a lot of mixed reaction but  one man in particular was  very emotional we told him derek chavin  was found guilty of all three charges  and we are in a tough time right now  just just  happy that we uh got a  perfect birdie not a perfect verdict  uh uh good birdie a guilty bird guilty  are you hoping this is the start of some  change  yeah we're a long way from change but  i hope that it does something that  gets us toys that way you know  i guess i'm really surprised that he was  all guilty that soon  myself um i thought it would take longer  now that second gentleman did go on to  tell me that he was satisfied with the  verdict  reporting live from the strip victoria  saha 8 news now